كــلّمـا اشتد التوتر بين روسيا والغرب، وكلما انطلقت مناورات توسيع النفوذ في الفضاءات الجيوسياسية الحسّاسة ،
إلا وأخذ حلف الناتو الواجهة الأولى للأحداث مضفيا عليها بعدا محتقنا بحكم طبيعته العسكرية
الأزمة الأوكرانية الأخيرة بمخرَجاتها السياسية والاقتصادية عمقت الشرخ بين روسيا والأطلسي
إلا أن اتخاذ الأزمة بينهما بعدا عسكريا جعل القوتين الواقفتين على طرفي نقيض أقربَ إلى مناخات الحرب الباردة.
فقد أعلن الأطلسي في قمته الأخيرة بــ/ويلز/ البريطانية عن:
نيته إنشاء أربع قواعد عسكرية في أوروبا الشرقية تحسبًـا  من ما سماه الخطر الروسي، مع الإبقاء على حضور دائم لقواته في تلك المنطقة.
قرر كذلك، تشكيلَ قوة للرد السريع تتألف من بين ثلاثة آلاف إلى خمسة آلاف جندي تكون قادرة على الانتشار على محاور حدودية مع روسيا في وقت قصير.
وكان امتعاض الروس من الأطلسي قد بدأ بضمه دولا أوروبية تقع في القسم الشرقي المجاور لروسيا.
ففي الثاني عشر من مارس آذار عام ألف وتسعمئة وتسعةٍ وتسعين ضم بولندا والتشيك والمجر،
وفي التاسع والعشرين من مارس/ آذار عام ألفين وأربعة، أُلحقت سبعُ دولٍ أخرى بالناتو منها دول البلطيق الثلاث إستونيا ولاتفيا وليتوانيا التي كانت في قوام الاتحاد السوفياتي سابقا.
وزارة الدفاع الروسية نبهت سابقا إلى أن توسع الناتو هو بمثابة إطلاق جولة جديدة من سباق التسلح،
وأكدت أنها ستضع عقيدة عسكرية جديدة تتلاءم مع المعطيات الجيوسياسية الراهنة..
فيما قال الكرملين إن’’مجرد خطوة أخرى للناتو باتجاه الحدود الروسية ستقود إلى إعادة تشكيل هياكل الأمن الأوروبي برمتها‘‘
وهو تحذير يحتمل أكثر من تفسير